>> SO TELL US ABOUT MAKING THE
SACRIFICED.
>> YOU KNOW, THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS, PARTICULARLY THE NEXT DAY
OR SO, RUN YOUR AIR CONDITIONING
EARLIER THE.
CLOSE YOUR WINDOWS, CLOSE YOUR
BLINDS.
TODAY AND TOMORROW AFTERNOON,
PLEASE TURN YOUR THERMOSTAT UP.
>> AND THIS IS THE STATE THAT
THE JOE BIDEN AND
ADMINISTRATIONS AS A LEADER AND
THESE POLICIES.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS BOLD ABOUT ENERGY
POLICY, A LEADER INDICATOR FOR
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY, PART OF
THE BOLDNESS HAS SHAPED OUR
WILLINGNESS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MOVE FURTHER AND
FASTER.
>> OKAY, I'M GOING TO START WITH
YOU.
THE ENERGY SECRETARY IS SO PROUD
OF CALIFORNIA.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THAT WE
HAVE TO WEAN OURSELVES OFF OF
FOSSIL FUELS
>> IT'S GOING TO TAKE A SHORTER
TIME FOR US TO GRADUATE.
>> SO I DON'T KNOW WHERE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM WAS, IT WASN'T
THE GREATEST LUCK IN THE WORLD
AND IT WAS HOT OUT THERE AND YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE CELEBRATE
TODAY, YOU KNOW, STEVE JOBS WAS
AS BIG OF A THINKER, AND AN
ENTREPRENEUR, HE WAS CRITICIZED
AND YOU HAD IDENTIFIED IT BEFORE
A FEW DAYS AGO, MADAM CJ WALKER
WAS A SELF-MADE MILLIONAIRE AND
I THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP, I
THINK ABOUT JOE BIDEN, ALSO
KENNEDY AS WELL.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABOUT BIG
MINDED PEOPLE, THEN I WOULD
SHORTSIGHTED PEOPLE WHEN IT
COMES TO BIG CHALLENGES.
AND WE NEED ALL OF THE ABOVE
ENERGY STRATEGY.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE IS A
TRANSITION.
>> CALIFORNIA IS LITERALLY IN A
BAD STATE.
AND IT'S THE CLIMATE CHANGE
ACTIVISTS THAT GET US INTO
HYSTERIA.
FORTY YEARS, 50 YEARS, IMAGINE
THAT.
AND IT MIGHT ACTUALLY, THE
CONSTANT HYPERBOLE, IT WOULD'VE
BEEN ON YOUR SIDE.
SO CYNICAL, THEN ALIENATED BY
THESE PEOPLE THAT WERE
CONSTANTLY FEAR MONGERING.
AND THEN I SAW THAT THE FEAR
MONGERING WAS BECOMING LIKE A
CASH COW AS WELL, YOU CAN SEE
ALL THESE SPECIALS, WHAT
EVERYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT IF
YOU WANT TO GET A GOOD MAGAZINE
PORTRAIT OR INTERVIEW, TALKING
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT, SUDDENLY
EVERYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT
CLIMATE.
BECAUSE IT WAS GOOD FOR THEIR
POCKETBOOK.
IT HAS TAKEN DECADES FOR NUCLEAR
POWER TO CUT BACK AND THEN THERE
ARE CYCLE BRATS LIKE GRETA
THUNBUR, YOUNG PEOPLE, LIKE HOW
DEAR YOU, HOW DARE YOU.
>> WHEN CALIFORNIA PASSED A LAW
TALKING ABOUT NOT BUYING GAS
POWERED CARS BEING LOUD AFTER
2035, THEY SAY, THEY ARE TRYING
TO WEAN THEIR WAY OUT OF THAT.
>> THEY DECIDED TO DO WHAT
CALIFORNIA DID, IT'S PART OF THE
WAY THAT THE DEMOCRATS WERE
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO GET A
FEDERAL LAW GOING.
AND THEN WE WILL BE ON THERE AS
WELL.
IT'S CLEVER WHEN ELECTRIC CARS
ARE GOING FROM WHAT THEY ARE
TODAY TO 100%, WITH NO NEW
ELECTRICITY.
WHEN WE ARE AT ENERGY CAPACITY.
IN ADDITION, PASSING
$300 BILLION OF AID TO THE GREEN
ENERGY COMPANIES.
THEN THEY PUT A VERY EFFECTIVE
DEMOCRATIC OPERATIVE AND CHARGED
FOR THAT MONEY WITH JOHN
PODESTA.
YOU KNOW, THIS WOULD BE SOLYNDRA
3.0.
END I AM ALL FOR BIG IDEAS.
TRUST ME.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU WILL GET
ONE FROM HERE IN THE MEANTIME,
ABOUT TO HAVE A DARK AND COLD
WINTER BECAUSE THEY HAD TERRIBLE
POLICIES THAT HAVE LED THEM TO
THIS MOMENT.
GEOPOLITICAL CRISIS ON OUR HAND.
DOING EVEN MORE TO HELP THEM,
BUT IT'S GREAT BUT WE HAVE NOT
KEPT UP WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WOULD YOU RATHER BITE LIQUID
NATURAL GAS IN THE UNITED
STATES?
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM, CALIFORNIA HAS A
WARNING FOR ALL OF US.
>> JUST AS IT WAS SAID,
CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO TALKED ABOUT
A LOT OF GAS POWERED PLANTS.
THEY ARE MAKING IT WORSE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WHAT IS RIGHT ON THE EDGE RIGHT
NOW, IT DOES NOT EVEN HAVE THE
NUMBER OF ELECTRIC CARS THAT
WILL BE THERE.
>> IT IS A FRAGILE GRID.
>> A WELL-BALANCED ABILITY TO
FUEL MY BODY.
I NEED GREENS, FRUITS, PROTEINS.
>> 100% GREEN IS A FAT AND THEY
ARE BURNING KEROSENE.
THEY ARE BURNING DIESEL AND THAT
INCLUDES 300,000 SQUARE MILES,
BUT IT ONLY POWERS 140,000
HOMES.
THE NATURAL GAS PLANT POWERS
16 MILLION.
MEANWHILE, IT IS INCINERATING
BURNERS.
AC BUGS, THEY FLY TO THE SOLAR
PANELS AND THEY BURST INTO
FLAMES.
IT IS ALSO KILLING THE TORTOISE
POPULATION.
AND I THOUGHT THAT THEY LOVED
TORTOISES.
BUT THEY DUMPED THIS ONE ON THE
INDIAN BURIAL GROUND.
IT'S NOT A G